France is shutting down museums
monuments and other high-profile
locations ahead of more violent protests
expected tomorrow thousands of
anti-government demonstrators have
burned cars and clashed with police last
weekend and the protests have now spread
all around the country Charlie d'Agata
is in the center of Paris with the
latest on this story Charlie good
morning good morning well they're doing
everything they can today to avoid a
repeat of the rioting tomorrow rioting
that included spray-painting graffiti on
the Arc de Triomphe and it looks an
awful lot like martial law look at this
video that's just emerged it shows high
school students on their knees with
their hands on their heads riot police
with batons and riot shields and a mass
arrests 190 students arrested the
youngest just 12 years old the Minister
of Education called it's shocking now
that comes after days of confrontation
where students threw stones and burn
trash cans as part of weeks of protests
that have rocked this country and
they're bracing for more tomorrow 89,000
security personnel deployed the Eiffel
Tower and other famous landmarks shut
down earlier this week French President
Emmanuel macron climbed down from the
fuel tax hike that sparked these riots
in the first place but even in retreat
his back is up against the wall
John Charlie d'Agata in Paris Thank You
charlie